what's popping Monster Hunters it's me
Mt and welcome back to the heavy
spoilers show spoilers for Monarch
Legacy of monsters episode 6 are coming
your way faster than Godzilla can hurl a
Titan telephone at some science nerds
because this right here is a breakdown
of that very episode an episode that
features the newest emergence of the
king of monsters in direct response to a
new and massively dangerous piece of
man-made technology that allows anyone
to make a collect call to a killer Kaiju
with convenience so let's just go ahead
and talk about it gang the episode
starts with us back in Ye Old olden days
of 1955 the year most famously known for
being the year that Marty McFly would
arrive in a time machine to get hit on
by his mom lots of therapy after that
one probably like I kind of wish Marty
McFly took his guitar shredding talents
on a tour to the American defense
industry federation's 1955 ball in
Washington DC cuz the music there needed
that McFly spice you know what I mean
like Marty would have for sure found a
way to make that Army band's rendition
of 1925's I'm sitting on the top of the
world by Ray Henderson Joe Young and Sam
Lewis a lot cooler than it came out on
the show but I really do like how they
started this particular episode with
that song because it kind of fits in
with the overall direction this episode
and the overall series is headed because
the lyrics of that song go I'm sitting
on top of the world just rolling along
just Rolling Along which I believe could
also refer to how Godzilla sits on top
of the planet Earth as king of all
monsters and life just rolling along the
surface of the planet Earth via
mysterious means mysterious means that
Monarch have been trying to decipher
ever since Koo Bill and Lee founded
Monarch all those years ago and the
lyrics continue later with yeah I just
phoned The Parson hey paw get ready to
call which fits quite well considering
that this episodes features Kate and
Cano's paw Hiroshi Randa getting ready
to call Godzilla with a miniaturized
modern-day version of the Titan phoning
gamma radiation simulating device
created by Dr Suzuki in 195 5 in order
to summon Godzilla from the depths of
the Earth but anyways the banner at the
party also tells us that the theme of
this gett together of military Minds is
Bali High which is of course the name of
the fictional island popularized in the
1949 play South Pacific in which Bali
High was perceived as a tropical island
Paradise by nearby military personnel in
that story actually fun fact a few years
ago I actually did sound for an entire
production of the play South Pacific so
I know that play quite well that story
balive was perceived as a tropical
island paradise where you could meet the
woman of your dreams by nearby military
personnel in that story so the American
Military throwing a Bali High themed
party six years after that play became
super popular is very fitting for that
time period but at the same time the
theme of Bali High can also be seen as a
bit of symbolic foreshadowing for the
kiss that Lee and Koo share on the
Monster Island of hauma but anyways when
KO and Lee are having a chat after
General Pucket and his buddies hit KO
with some 1955 style racism Lee attempts
to soothe koo's anxieties by telling her
that she is a force of nature with the
power to change people's minds and I
really love that line because it
establishes a symbolic parallel between
Koo and Godzilla himself as a force of
nature with the power to change people's
minds is exactly what Godzilla is as
well especially to Lee Shaw specifically
because as we can see towards the end of
this episode The olderly Shaw of 2015
has a completely different opinion about
Godzilla than his younger self when he
finally tells the group that he's been
secretly working to help Godzilla this
entire time and it was Koo herself who
first planted the seed of change within
Lee's mind all those years ago when her
heart broke at the sight of the full
might of the American Military being
used against a Monster who holds No
Malice towards man but after this Lee
and Koo danc to 1940s you stepped out of
a Dream by Gus Khan and nasio her Brown
while a bunch of racist weirdos watch
them then they have a conversation about
their potential Futures where Lee brings
up the idea of being a career military
man and making lots of babies ideally
with Koo which is a conversation that
Koo would refer to four years after this
in 1959 during the car ride in
Kazakhstan hours before Koo got bugged
out of existence way back in episode one
then we shift to the modern day where it
appears that Michelle Duvall has
betrayed Monarch in order to free and
join up with Lee Shaw when she does she
reveals that Monarch is comprised of
some of the best nuclear physicists
geologists and zoologists in the world
before Shaw himself reveals that the
motivations for what he's been doing are
rooted in regret specifically the regret
of not doing enough to help Godzilla in
the past like Koo always wanted Shaw
seems to be going on a journey to honor
the woman that he loved in the past
while running from the very organization
that became corrupted by military
mentality because of one foolish mistake
that he made because of that love for KO
but anyway shortly after this Michelle
Duval tells Lee Shaw that she joined
Monarch in large part because her sister
Shandra died during the Kaiju attack in
jira Japan which is a fictional
monsterverse city introduced in the 2014
Godzilla film in fact Sandra herself was
in that movie as well cuz if you
remember Sandra Brody was the wife of
Brian cranston's Joseph Brody who died
due to exposure to radiation at a
nuclear power plant because a giant Muto
Kaiju from that movie was feasting on
the plant Radioactive material so being
Sandra's grieving sister Michelle seems
to have joined Monarch after that 2014
Kaiju craziness and is still relatively
new to the agency after only being there
for around a year however despite
Michelle being a grieving sister this
doesn't necessarily mean that she's
completely telling Lee Shaw the truth
here I mean she might be genuine about
joining Lee to stop another Titan attack
considering that we can see tears well
up in Michelle's eyes when she is
vulnerable about her sister but at the
same time last episode we did see duv
advising assistant director rugo and Tim
that they let Kate canaro May and Lee go
in order for Monarch to keep them on a
short leash and be able to follow them
while also seeing Duval essentially
threaten May into taking a traitorous
deal so there is a big chance here that
Duval has been walking the protagonist
on that very short leash this entire
time but there's also the possibility
that Duval is merely using both Monarch
and Lee in order to try to stop the
emergence of titans in her own way but
only time will tell there like I
honestly feel like Duval will end up
working with Apex cybernetics down the
road because those guys are a major
force in Godzilla versus Kong because
those jerks end up making meca Godzilla
which could be something that Duval
would want made to stop other Titans
from emerging but either way dual is a
super Shady Lady man but then soon after
when we head back to 1955 I love the
huge smile KO has when Bill Randa says
the words I don't know because she had
just told Lee Shaw at that party that
her favorite thing about kids was their
openness to admit that they don't know
combined with their eagerness to search
for the truth so that smile is
definitely when KO started falling in
love with Bill randa's childlike science
Wonder because a man like that would be
able to produce an equally inquisitive
child which is exactly what Koo and Bill
Randa do with their son Hiroshi a man
who was too curious for his own damn
good when he asked himself questions
like I wonder if I can summon Godzilla
at will and what does cheating on two
secret families feel like whoops but
anyways when assistant director Verdugo
and Tim are trying to piece together the
map the gang took from hiroshi's San
Francisco office Tim channels his inner
Columbo to discover that all the points
on hiroshi's map correspond to the
Monarch outposts that bill Randa had the
most interest in in his files with all
of these sites not so coincidentally
having kaijus located near them you know
like how in Godzilla king of monsters we
learned that Mathra was being housed at
Monarch Outpost 61 on infant island in
Indonesia while gdor was being housed in
Outpost 64 in Baffin Island Canada while
pointing to and naming the different
Outpost locations to assistant director
Verdugo Tim mentions another Outpost
four on the American West Coast near
California an outpost 15 near Japan and
an outpost 47 somewhere near Australia
with that last one being super confusing
to me for a few minutes considering that
episode 4 revealed to us that agent
Barnes was stationed at Outpost 47 in
Utah so I was like aha Timothy the
monster nerd made a mistake AK and I
should have his job instead what an
idiot but it turns out I was the one
that was being the idiot because
apparently there's a Utah in New South
Wales which for sure resides in that
Oceana region that Tim was pointing to
so if you thought that aent Barnes was
chilling in America think again but
anyways back in 1955 Bill and KO head
off to hatara Island which is a Japanese
island South of the Mainland but what is
significant about this island in
legendaries monsterverse is that it
appears to be an adaptation of monster
Island introduced in 1969's Godzilla all
monsters attack and further expounded in
1972's Godzilla versus gagan in the
original Godzilla Universe Monster
Island was of course the island that a
number of Titan monsters like Mathra and
Rodan lived on but in this new legendary
monsterverse monster Island appears to
be huruma island which is just one of
the many places on Earth Kaiju can
emerge from likely due to all of those
holes at all of those gamma radiation
locations that lead towards the hollow
Earth which is why monsters keep being
found near all of Bill and hiroshi's
outpost sites they're all popping out of
various Hollow Earth Wormhole tunnels
from within the planet that radiate a
ton of gamma radiation when those
portals are being activated though we
are formerly introduced to Dr Suzuki's
gamma radiation simulator in episode 6
we actually got a quick glimpse of the
device on Monster Island all the way
back in episode 1 when may is looking
through the random files on her computer
but what's particularly interesting
about Suzuki's gamma radiation simulator
is that it very much feels like the
predecessor to the similarly devastating
Orca device that was Central to The
Narrative of Godzilla king of monsters
in 2019 as Mark and Emma Russell's
Orchid device was also used to call
Kaiju to a particular location but
instead of gamma radiation the Orca
simulated the vocals of monsters in
order to bait Titans to the source of
those simulated screeches but anyways in
2015 the gang make their way down to the
Algerian desert to try and at Hiroshi
Randa and oh my god there he is in the
Algerian desert just casually chilling
in his pickup truck with his mini gamma
radiation simulator completely
forgetting how to give his family a
goddamn phone call but honestly now that
we know that Hiroshi has been
experimenting with a gamma radiation
simulator to bait Kaiju to his location
that would sort of explain why he's been
completely avoiding his family
especially given his frantic reaction to
seeing his kids for the first time in
forever like this man definitely wanted
to keep keep his family safe from his
line of work in more ways than one
because he couldn't well experiment with
such a device around the people that he
loved or any sort of populated area but
anyways after Godzilla emerges and lets
out his classic Scream the Monarch
helicopter that was carrying Tim and a
bunch of Monarch goons bumps into
Godzilla like a bunch of dinguses and is
sent crashing off screen with Le Shaw
later confirming that nobody on the
helicopter survived the crash however if
you look at Lee Shaw's hands when he's
walking from the wreckage you can see
that this man is brand ing a gun
definitely making me feel like there's a
chance that Lee might have killed any
surviving Monarch agents in that
helicopter even Tim but that has yet to
be seen but that is it for this
breakdown of Monarch Legacy of monsters
episode 6 like I truly hope that Kate
can find a way to forgive May after her
betrayal because those two have grown
super close over the course of this show
and I'm really hoping that they get
together by the end of the narrative
because they have been extremely
supportive of one another but regardless
let us know what you guys think is going
to happen in the next episode and in the
future of monarch in the comment section
below you can follow Me @ mastertainment
on Twitter Instagram or wherever I am on
the internet especially on the Guardians
of the paly podcast here on YouTube
where you can see me my friends Whitney
and Tommy talk about some really fun
nerd stuff but most importantly you can
follow heavy spoilers here on YouTube
and do not forget to hit that
notification Bell so that you can get
notifications every time we upload a
video and hey leave this video a like if
you liked it because that really helps
out the channel as well but again thank
you guys for watching you guys are
amazing and I appreciate each and every
one of you please be kind to each other
and I'll see you guys next time goodbye